okay why don't we go ahead and get
started welcome everyone i-i know it's
between terms but i appreciate everyone
coming to hear our guests talk so it's
it's a great pleasure to introduce dr.
julian hong who is currently a resident
in radiation oncology has one year left
on that meaning that in about well he'll
probably start looking for a job soon
but will be hopefully finding a job in
in a year and he's he's exploring many
different institutions including on the
west coast here i was actually
introduced to him by a good friend of
mine who is at duke dr. jessie Tenenbaum
some of you may know her she's very
active in a mia and so forth and she
told me about this radiation oncology
resident who did this really great EHR
data a project with her so that's how i
got to meet him at the amias summit but
in any case dr. hong has has a lot of
training he actually got a bachelor's
degree from Stanford and biomedical
computation in 2008 then got a master's
degree in bioengineering at Stanford at
that point he decided he want to go to
medical school so he went to the
University of Wisconsin where he
graduated with this MD degree as
radiation oncologist often do he did a
year of internal medicine at Yale before
doing his residency at Duke where he is
now and along the way he's had interests
in informatics and he's going to tell us
a little bit about that
so um dr. Hong
you
okay I think we all set all right cool
and hello to everybody who's online now
the microphone is on
all right well it's like a Hirsch
mentioned I'm a radiation oncology
resident at Duke right now and my
research interested in trying to bring
informatics the clinic so I'll be
chatting with you guys about that today
and some of our most recent work so
first things first I don't have any
disclosures so this is what we'll be
talking about so I have at least my
young career found it interesting to
hear people's stories and kind of how
they ended up where they're at and
everybody kind of has a different path
to where they're trying to go we'll talk
a little bit in broad terms both about
radiation oncology analytics informatics
and then we'll talk about trying to
bring some of those tools to enhance the
care for our patients and in my case you
know taking care of patients with cancer
and getting passed maybe some of the
hype that we you know hear about in the
media and everything so so it wouldn't
be like a map with that like an Indiana
Jones theme so so as dr. Hirsh mentioned
my academic career started at Stanford
there my interest was primarily in
imaging analytics and in cardiovascular
biomechanics so at that time it's any of
the radiation oncologists in the room
will appreciate that I was already
contouring like random stuff at that
time when we were doing imaging
analytics which is like a big part of
our job these days and got a chance to
interface the radiation oncology
department there which is kind of how I
got introduced we did a lot of work on
quantifying fiducial markers used for
lung tumors as far as their migration
and then trying to improve our ability
to image pulmonary tumors which is
really critical to our ability to treat
lung cancer from there I went to the
University of Wisconsin where I got a
chance to work on relational databases
and clinical outcomes we looked at a
number of like the national databases
and sort of their different linked
billing sources and I was sort of my
like real introduction to doing patient
outcomes related work kind of with
informatics slants kind of continued
that work when I joined an internal
medicine program at Yale where
interfaced with what they called a
copper group which works on cancer
outcomes and they have a very robust
system they're looking at different
types of data and of course move down to
Duke where I'm at now and have had the
chance to interface with a lot of
different really just bright people and
I've gotten to learn a whole lot and as
dr. Hirsh mentioned got a chance to work
with Jessie Tannenbaum there who does a
lot of work on EHR based research in the
area of Psychiatry so we've gotten a
chance to put together some cool
collaborations so I know we kind of have
an audience with a lot of different
backgrounds so we'll kind of cover the
gamut of different things but just a
little bit about kind of our clinical
day-to-day as radiation oncologists so
radiation for whatever whatever reason
is is something that I think people are
a little bit less aware of when they
experience cancer treatment but about
half of patients will actually undergo
radiation in some form or another when
they're diagnosed with cancer it is an
important part of the curative treatment
for a number of cancers it's actually
the definitive treatment for a number of
different diseases and radiation courses
can very very highly you know we see
folks from you know one treatment up to
seven weeks of treatment and so it's a
very diverse patient population a
diverse set of treatments and it's often
used in conjunction with other things
that folks are familiar with so surgery
now often either before after with
chemotherapy so an important treatment
modality in the management of cancer so
just a quick kind of over cartoon
overview so I'll kind of mostly focus on
external beam radiation which kind of is
the bulk of what we do on a day to day
basis but we also do other forms of
radiation treatments but a patient who's
getting external beam radiation will
often come in we'll do a CT scan that
helps us generate a computer model of
their body and then based on that will
actually work with our medical
physicists to develop a radiation
treatment plan and so this is kind of
what we look at when we evaluate
radiation treatment plants this is an
example of a patient who's undergoing
radiate
per head neck cancer so this is kind of
there if they're lying on their back and
then face it with their feet towards you
and then facing up towards the wall so
you can kind of see their teeth and so
the radiation plan is sort of a weather
map for the dose distribution of where
the radiation is going and the idea is
that we use advanced imaging techniques
to deliver a radiation specifically
where we want to go so we kind of aim
the radiation try to minimize the
radiation that goes to normal structures
an important part of what we do on a day
to day basis and then the patient comes
in they have often daily treatments they
lie down on a table that's very similar
to I usually describe it as very similar
to having x-rays done every day on a
day-to-day basis and they go through
their treatment and the side effects of
radiation are cumulative and very much
diseased and site-specific and we'll
actually talk a little bit more about
that as we're getting to the talk but
you know patients can get treated for up
to 7 weeks and we're often sort of their
main clinical contact during their
treatments and so we're often the sort
of primary clinician responsible for
their care during that period of time
and so we have very close clinical
management of our patients and it's
actually relevant to some of the work
that obvious asking you today as well so
it's probably not an audience where I
need to overhype like analytics I'll
probably need to under hype analytics
but in the of course in the popular
media you know we're constantly hearing
about applications of AI just a laundry
list of things and of course IBM Watson
which has been relevant to some cancer
related efforts in various domains ai is
actually probably done used for things
that we probably shouldn't be applying
it to but it forms a major component of
analytics and informatics forms a major
component of my research interests so I
can't go through a talk about Analects
without talking about sports a little
bit sky how I am and I'd say probably
like my first you know I did a lot of
informatics based research and imaging
analytics based research but sort of my
first foray into like predictive
analytics is in sports and
and a child of the Moneyball era and so
I think the most sort of important
lesson that I've gotten from that is
that all of us have important things
that we can learn from other disciplines
that are doing analogous projects in
other areas and I think that there are
interesting things that we can learn
from other disciplines and one of my
hobbies on the side is actually to work
on predicting Ric results from the NCAA
tournament every year and any college
basketball fans remember Villanova had a
pretty proud a pretty solid run through
the tournament for any Villanova fans
and so my brother and I actually compete
in the annual tagil competition for
March Madness and so I'll get to the
lessons here eventually I promise but I
actually tracked the score socal goals
scored on the log loss scale you
basically try to estimate the
probability of like a specific team
winning and so you want to lower score
and so we do it for fun I just try to my
goal is for any of the political junkies
or analytics like media junkies I just
try to beat nate silver in 538 on an
annual basis but you can kind of see
some of the major events that happen in
this year's tournament and actually
incidentally I promise this is us we
actually finished in third and picked up
a little bit of change and incidentally
I feel like this guy actually got more
attention in my department than some of
my research so but a lot of lessons
learned here so there's a little some of
the details about our model I won't go
into like the basketball stuff but I
think that these are kind of themes that
I kind of locked like to talk about I
think important to think about the
domain of your problem thinking about
you know making like making good
decisions and how you curate your data
is really critical and thinks methods
you know we're in an era where we have
all these complex techniques like deep
learning and you know even though those
complex techniques are really sexy you
know there are trade-offs for those
techniques and so it's important to kind
of think about you know what your goals
are with different problems and
sometimes you know other types of
techniques can work
pretty well so alright so enough fun
we'll get to some clinical
decision-making so you know so as a
physician you know we have a lot of
points where we need to make really
important decisions
I'd say the basis of our sort of cancer
training is to think about you know what
kinds of treatments are the most
appropriate management for a patient who
comes in the door with cancer and so the
way that we make decisions is largely
granted on our physician training so you
know I'm finishing up the fifth year of
post I guess like post medical school
training and so you know we learn during
this period of time a lot about the
prior studies so there's the sort of
hierarchy or pyramid of different grades
of evidence and those are all things
that we kind of learn about and we try
to integrate into our clinical practice
and then as you you know spend more time
in the clinic you rely very heavily on
clinical experience to kind of drive
some of that decision-making you know in
the clinic and so for any fans of like
thinking fast and slow like you know a
lot of sort of different heuristic
techniques things that are human that
that sort of inform our decision-making
for better or worse and there's a lot of
information to synthesize and a lot of
potential sources of bias and so you
know we're still human and so there are
certain things that we do very well and
there are certain things that we don't
do quite as well and so there are
certain domains where you know
information technology and analytics can
really serve to improve our ability to
take care of patients and so you know
analytical techniques
I think play a role in a number of
domains I just kind of pointed out like
knowledge discovery so in an era of
omics you know we use a lot of
analytical techniques to try to generate
new hypotheses and generate new data but
I think sort of my interest has mostly
been in trying to improve our ability to
make clinical decisions and so we'll
kind of focus on on that in this talk
and I think that in in a lot of ways
those two areas go hand-in-hand so so
how do we make decisions in the clinic
so we rely heavily on different sources
of information
and rely heavily on things that are
readily digestible in the clinic and so
in cancer imaging is an important
component of our decision-making and
often times you know we sit there we
look at an image and we try to glean
information from it sometimes we try to
simplify it with really basic
quantitative adjuncts and so this is a
study that we did looking at PET scans
for in the during the treatment of anal
cancer as sort of an example we
typically do PET scans and anal cancer
before treatment and we do it after
treatment but one of the things that we
tried incorporating at Duke was doing it
during treatment to see if it gave us
sort of any independent information and
one thing that we found was that you
know if you took a look at an image and
or you had a Radiology's radiologist
review the image the certain
discriminatory ability was not quite as
strong as using quantitative metrics
even basic quantitative metrics I kind
of cherry-pick the case so it's like
kind of easy to tell visually but most
of the cases don't end up like this but
so the top row is one patient the bottom
row is another patient the first scan is
sort of what it looked like what their
cancer looked like before they started
treatment and so you can see that at you
can take my word for it but the two
images are pretty sort of similar and
they actually have similar quantitative
metrics but then you know when you get
the second scan during their treatment
you can see that there's a big
difference in the patient has a a better
scan which is sort of less red is had a
basically had a better outcome and so
this kind of was born at in our study so
that's kind of a sort of a simple case
but different types of things that we
apply to try to help us make treatment
decisions the clinicians in the room
will probably recognize nomograms
because they're a popular visualization
tool for sort of basic digestible
information in the clinic this is a
study that one of my co residents I
worked on so in prostate cancer we rely
heavily or so in prostate cancer a
fundamental part of the treatment is
what we calls four simple terms hormonal
therapy or androgen deprivation and so
we often sort of the discussion with the
patient often is based is granted in the
assumption that there is the side
effects of androgen deprivation
are essentially temporary and so their
testosterone will recover at some point
and so one of the questions that were
often asked in the clinic is well you
know doc when is my testosterone I'm
gonna go back to normal when it when is
winner the side effects going to go away
and so we put together a nomogram for
trying to predict you know how
testosterone recovers essentially and so
this is sort of another piece of
clinical decision-making that we use
there are a number of different Numa
grams that sort of play a role in
medical care a lot of them are on apps
on your iPhone in the clinic these days
and they give you sort of a digestible
piece of information that you can use to
inform things and then the last thing
sort of as we transition to more
advanced analytics is a sort of the
decision tree analysis and so I often
present this to clinicians because it's
sort of in it's a familiar form because
a lot of studies particularly in cancer
are built on decision trees that
separate out groups into simple
variables and so the nice thing about
decision trees is that they are sort of
the basis of a lot of our machine
learning techniques and so it's kind of
a good starting point for clinicians so
this is a study we put together that
looked at patients that had what we call
all ago metastatic cancer which is sort
of limited metastatic cancer that's
treated with aggressive radiation
therapy and the idea was to try to break
them out into groups that have
differential outcomes and so one of the
nice things about these models that
clinicians sort of always ask about is
like how what goes into the model how is
it interpretable because I think that
that's one of our major barriers for
using more advanced analytic techniques
in the clinic and so you know there's a
trade-off between simplicity models or
complexity models and predictive
accuracy and so it's it's important to
sort of keep in mind that need for some
interpretability for clinicians when
they're trying to you know explain
things to the patients and try to
motivate their clinical decision making
so just kind of a quick overview but you
know machine learning in the past
year-plus or so has had a number of like
predictive successes that have been
really just popularized in the media
they're often ways to sort of manage
high-dimensional day
they're typically classification
problems and one thing I always like to
point out is that they're often
analogous to problems that are in other
domains and other you know areas of
study and it's part of why I think that
there's a lot to learn from you know how
we advance science in other areas and
trying to bring them to our discipline
but one of the major caveats is that
their integration into clinical practice
is still very much a work in progress
and that's kind of one of the areas that
I'm sort of interested in and trying to
to work on so just a couple of quick
examples recently the FDA I believe that
idx was one of the first FDA approved AI
based devices that basically detected
diabetes related eye issues signal
processing techniques can be used for
looking at cardiovascular disease and
electrophysiology visual image analytics
can be used for identifying melanomas
which actually interestingly there was
while we're talking about integrating
things in the clinic there was actually
a recent study that compared melanoma
and skin cancer classification versus
physicians that was published in the
annals of oncology and then there was a
big effort that got a lot of press I
think from Google UCSF and UChicago that
tried to look at Hospital outcomes based
on EHR based data as particularly
relevant to some of the stuff that I do
and so some interesting type work so you
know we we are in this domain that has a
lot of data as a radiation oncology is
no different from a lot of Medical
Specialties I'd argue probably we rely
very heavily on data and so we have
imaging front that's typically in a
radiology pack system our treatment
planning itself is a huge source of data
for us in addition to that we often do
real-time image I guess routine imaging
during treatment which and also give us
some data and then of course everybody's
favorite piece of software is the
electronic health record is a vast area
of data so within the EHR there's tons
of information I don't think that that's
readable as it is but there you know
there are a lot of data that exists in
structured data forms and so this is
actually a study that
doing with the co-operative Studies
group in the VA over at Duke basically
looking at all of the different
structured comorbidity data that's
present in the EHR system and how they
relate to each other chronologically but
I think it serves as a good visual
representation for just like how much
stuff there is and how much you need to
sort of think about making things into
appropriate scales to make them
manageable and usable in analytics I
always bring this slide up for the
clinicians but this is a study in
primary care physicians and how they use
how they use the EHR and there's only
one number that I want to highlight
which is 49.2%
which is the amount of time the primary
care doctors use tabulating data in the
electronic health record and so we spend
a tremendous amount of time as
physicians putting data into the EHR but
it's often felt to be very difficult to
get data out of the EHR and so this is
actually the first google image search
you get when you look up med student
computer but a lot of the retrospective
clinical studies are grounded in manual
review of patient charts often by med
students by residents where you know we
spend a lot of time just trying to pull
information out it's tedious and can
often be error-prone and so you know you
want to take this and transform it into
this where you could have computers do
more of the work for you it doesn't have
to be c-3po but this is sort of how we
get to that learning healthcare system
so in radiation oncology there have been
a lot of applications of machine
learning I think most strongly in basic
science with the use of different omics
medical physics has actually done a
really good job of like taking the lead
in using advanced analytics purely I
think by the fact that it's a very
quantitative discipline and so they've
sort of incorporated a lot of really
interesting work as far as imaging
analytics and trying to put together
treatment planning systems but there's
been limited work on clinical outcomes
and really just trying to implement
things in the clinic so our work focuses
there the work that I'll focus on here
it's primarily related to trying to
improve the quality of care for cancer
patients and I think that for certain
complex predictions that are sort of
different you know the goals of your
prediction models are different from
some of the types of models that I
presented earlier those kind of require
more complex systems and I think that
you're willing to compromise some in the
simplicity of the model to make more
accurate predictions and so during
radiation treatments about ten to twenty
percent of patients will actually get
admitted during their care it's very
dependent on what kind of disease site
they're being treated for and so that
can result in a number of bad things for
one ending up in the hospital or the ER
is not a good thing but when when that
happens it also can often result in
treatment breaks which can compromise
cancer outcomes in radiation therapy and
it can also of course result in
increased healthcare costs and it's been
a real priority for CMS and and
insurance payers really try to
prioritize this and so this was actually
a review that was recently done that
highlighted some of the best practices
and I think extend from you know not
just general and collage acara but also
to radiation oncology and you know I
kind of hone in on trying to identify
patients that are at high risk for
having unplanned you know ER visits or
hospitalizations and of course you know
they have one of the lines is predictive
analytics and I think that that's sort
of the first step in the chain in trying
to improve cancer outcomes and as dr.
Hirsch and I were discussing earlier
like these kinds of projects are very
popular because of how the endpoint is
defined but I think that there's there
are a lot of sort of important things to
think about when we're putting together
these machine learning models so you
know in this case one is how well can we
predict the event I think that
oftentimes we you know there have been
so many publications looking at you know
predictive modeling and looking at AUC
curves and it's like oh yeah we can do a
really good job of predicting this you
know issue and in this case trying to
predict ER visits and hospitalizations
during radiation treatment but there are
other sub questions that we really
should be asking because those are the
barriers to getting these things in the
clinic so one is can we actually do
something with this with this knowledge
and as
you know I've spoken to folks at other
institutions that's been part of the
issues they designed these really
accurate predictive models but then it's
really hard to do something to change
the outcome or it's really hard to
design a study that will show that you
can intervene and actually make a
difference without it taking years and
years and years or something like that
and so that's that's I think a really
important thing to keep in mind and you
know at the end of the day our goal is
to try to find ways to get at an ends
which is high value and high quality
cancer care for our patients and so I
think it's important to kind of keep
that end in mind when you're sort of
thinking about you know the pathway of
putting this these studies together so
we've got so if George Costanza like
walks in the room you want to be able to
say hey this guy is at high risk for
admission I want to be able to do
something to improve that and so in this
context there's actually been data from
UNC that basically showed that more
aggressive supportive care during
radiation treatment actually reduce the
risk of acute care visit so in their
study they basically implemented what
they called a symptom management clinic
and so their baseline rate was 16
percent of patients with head neck
cancer that were unselected ended up in
the ER in the hospital when they
implemented this clinic they actually
reduce that rate from 16 percent to 10
percent but they used it in an
unselected fashion so that can be very
resource-intensive they're actually
rolling it out to other disease sites
now but on our side we sort of thought
you know is there a way that we can sort
of really efficiently try to provide
this high-value care without being quite
as resource intensive and so that was
kind of the goal of the project so we
took so so Jessie Tannenbaum and I put
together this collaboration where we
took our entire patient experience over
the epic era at Duke so that was over
the past four years and we started out
with the structured EHR data from the
Duke data warehouse which I'll talk a
little bit about in a second and then we
also took data from the radiation
oncology EHR so the radiation oncology
data at least at duke is often very
siloed off from epic and so there are
two sort of separate sources of data
that on occasion talk to each other to
transmit like things like appointment
information sometimes not a hundred
percent accurately but there's there too
separate silos then we use multiple
machine learning techniques to try to
predict the rate of acute encounters
during the treatment so the goal is to
try to direct clinical intervention so
the problem I think is a sort of a
straightforward classification problem
and trying to take high dimensional data
out of the EHR so a little bit about
kind of how at least I think about
structured data so as a physician it's
been like pounded into me like sort of
how the clinical encounter goes and so I
thought this was a cute graphic from the
80s but the date says late 90s but in
either case it's from an old Mac but
this is kind of how we think about like
the data that we need to collect when we
walk into a clinic room and see a
patient and I think often times sort of
that you know that's a very rational
approach to try to clinical information
gathering and I think that those sorts
of things can be extended to how we
think about the data that we need to
incorporate into our predictive models
and so we collect information like the
patient's chief complaint you know sort
of what's going on with them all their
past medical history medications things
like that and I think that these are all
things that in some way can get
represented with data that's already
structured in the EHR and so this is a
depiction of the Duke data warehouse
system and so we have the benefit of the
deduce system at Duke which actually
pulls data from the clarity database
which pulls stuff in like the operations
EHR and so these are sort of all of the
data that we you know try to incorporate
into our algorithms I'd be remiss if I
didn't talk about how like at least I
spent like 80 percent of my time so the
machine learning stuff is in vogue and
on hype but most of the time that we
spend in analytics is just cleaning data
try to make it into useable formats and
I think that this is sort of an area
where I think you know again domain
domain knowledge and sort of
conscientious consideration of what the
problem you're trying to solve is very
very important and so you know you have
all this data in the EHR but it's often
you know in different difference at
different scales it's at different
levels that are sort of different from
you know the information that you know
we would be thinking about in the clinic
so for instance if a patient comes in
with a tonsil cancer you know it's
represented by specific icd-10 code a we
kind of often think about head and neck
cancers as one sort of conglomerate
group which is a number of diseases that
are fairly similar and an Tomica Lee
close to each other
oftentimes the side effects so those
treatments are very similar to each
other and so even those two patients
might have different ICD codes so a
patient has let's say a base of tongue
cancer and a patient has tonsil cancer
those entities are not you know they're
not particularly different from each
other and so it's important to sort of
think about like how data needs to be
reprocessed into sort of rational
rational things and you know it's it's
probably like the least exciting part
but I think it's the part they got it
gets you the most mileage and probably
where you spend most of your time
medications in the EHR or in
particularly like an issue so you have a
number of different types of medications
they have different doses they're
represented as distinct entities and
it's important to think about you know
different medications that have or let's
say one medication has multiple names so
you want to make sure that those
medications are put together and then
you also have to think about medication
classes because oftentimes medications
are fundamentally you know
interchangeable with each other and so
it's important to kind of represent that
logic and trying to put together the
data and so that's sort of part of what
we did vital science I think is a really
interesting area that I think could be
explored more with like time series and
and deep learning and for the simplicity
sake in this project we kind of just
format it down to like physician to find
abnormal ranges so these are all data
that came from before the patient's
treatment so the idea was to take all
data before patients treatment put
together a prediction you know the
second that they start their treatment
so you have something to kind of go into
things with so training and test cohorts
as the norm so these three quarters of
our data for the training cohort and the
quarter for the tests
and these are the machine learning
algorithms that we use I'll talk a
little bit about those for the
clinicians in the room and as I kind of
think of two controls that we use so
there's the lasso logistic regression
which I think it's sort of it's probably
the best way to try to approximate
logistic regression model to make it
like something that's interpretive for a
clinician and then we also used a
gradient tribu system that basically
limited variables to cancer and
treatment related things because I think
as clinicians we sort of see a patient
we're sort of thinking like well those
are the things that are probably going
to predict whether or not someone has
issues during their treatment so just
really quick review of some of the
machine learning techniques so gradient
tree boosting as I mentioned before
decision trees sort of the baseline
learner for a lot of these models
greeting tree boosting I think of often
as like in series and so you generate a
series of decision trees that sort of
basically continue to build on the like
residuals of one of the preceding tree
and so you put all these trees together
and you come up with a prediction and in
contrast I often contrast it to the
random force which is instead of in
series you have trees that are in
parallel they're a bunch of sort of weak
decision trees that you can sort of put
together and as a team they're able to
make more accurate predictions
I always think support vector machines
are kind of a cool picture but you know
if you have all of the black so all the
black dots representing patients that
end up with a cube visit white dots
representing patients that you know go
through treatment without any issues and
then you you know you basically want to
create this plane where you can separate
out the patients and you know this is
what it looks like in two dimensions but
you know with thousands of variables
like we have in the EHR you know much
more complex things to visualize but I
always think it's a good visualization I
talked about lasso already there's not
like a great picture of the lasso
logistic regression so I won with Wonder
Woman's lasso of truth but the idea is
there are better pictures for
overfitting and so the idea being that
if the blue dots represent patients that
are admitted or having ER visit and red
dots that represent those who do not
lasso gives you it takes you from the
green line which draws is perfect you
know separation and a training set but
it's not as generalizable versus the
curve for the for the blue dots the idea
being that you know you want to prevent
overfitting by regularizing so a little
bit about the results so these are how
models performed and I think I already
harped on like having a bunch of a ECS
but I'll show you a table of ACS anyway
and and so you can see the take-home
point that I usually take from this data
is that you know you can pick a machine
learning technique and they often work
pretty well and often times you know
some work better than others in certain
situations depending on the problem or
the context that you're trying to to
work within but the gradient treat the
gradient boosted tree has the highest
performance and I often think that it's
very useful to translate for clinicians
you know sort of what this means because
in a you see is this sort of unified
number that basically takes you know all
these results along an ROC curve but
often times you know a collision says
well what does that exactly mean like
when you're trying to make a prediction
for a patient and so if you pick a cut
point that's based computationally you
know for example you can have a
sensitivity of 81% compared to a
specificity of 67% and you can make
trade-offs depending on where you want
to sit in the curve depending on what
your clinical resources are or how you
want to manage the problem whether
you're more willing or less willing to
accept you know false positives or false
negatives the last so I always point out
did a fairly good job so it's always
important not to forget your old friend
logistic regression which is you know I
think by far the most interpretable
technique and then gradient tree
boosting with just sort of simplified
variables did the worst so I think that
that the idea of showing that comparison
is to show that you can get more
predictive accuracy by incorporating
height you know larger scale high
dimensional data into the prediction
model the other part in assessing model
performance is calibration and so you
want to be along with straight line you
want your prediction probability to
compare well with the actual probability
and so you know that has a pretty good
visual so interpretation of models so I
think every clinicians favorite thing
but I think it's important to you know
keep this in mind and I think that in
all different fields of analytics
interpretation has become like an
emerging
emerging concern and so I think it's
really important to keep in mind at the
very least for tree based and decision
decision decision tree based systems we
have the benefit of looking at how many
times a variable or how often a variable
contributes to the prediction I always
tell people like when you sort of peek
behind the curtain to try to exercise a
little bit of caution in a strict
interpretation because there's so many
correlated variables and whatnot but for
a clinician a lot of these variables
make sense so like if you had asked me
if a patient has more treatments or you
know or they're receiving chemotherapy
because they're their treatments is more
intense like do you expect them to be
more likely to have an acute event and
I'd say yes and so I often think of you
know variable importance as sort of a
way to do like a sanity check it gives
your clinical judgement and so I kind of
color-coded this graph to show that
there's a diverse lot of data that plays
an important role in empowering these
predictions and I always point out the
scale because that scale only goes up to
0.07 so none of the variables really
when you take everything and put it
together even though it looks like
treatment number of radiation treatments
dominates the model it actually does not
comprise a huge amount of the predictive
value of the model so you can see that
there are a number of sort of different
types of variables that they include you
know the encounters that they had in the
HR the lab result that they had in the
EHR and so all sort of important things
that play a role in the prediction so
the next steps are really important and
I think that the first is sort of you
know how you know how do you get machine
learning techniques implemented in the
clinic like how do we take the next step
and for a better or worse sort of our
gold standard is still the clinical
trial and then I you know I think that
we're always trying to make predictive
models better and so jesse and i both
have an interest in and trying to use
and LP techniques and trying to get
unstructured data harness to improve our
predictive abilities I'll talk a little
bit about that so clinical trials I
think like most of my attendings let's
say like oh yeah like you know like how
do we get this in the clinic like what
is how are you going to test it and I
think like at the end
it often comes down to like having some
kind of prospective evaluation and some
kind of comparison in the clinic I think
the other component of things is
external validation because data is
collected differently at different
institutions and so you know it depends
on sort of how you think about models
whether they're sort of a modeling
approach at one institution that you can
apply at another institution or if it
the model you generated at one
institution can you apply that model in
another place and so I think those are
both kind of valid ways of like looking
at trying to solve the problem but
really the question is you know how well
does it work in the clinic how does the
computer compared to a physician's
prediction and whether or not there's
and there's incremental improvements in
our ability to intervene with patients
so this is actually a clinical trial
that we're putting together I actually
just finished writing the protocol but
hopefully we'll get this off the ground
soon but we're going to take all of the
patients that we treat in our department
at Duke and we're basically going to
calculate a risk score for every patient
that walks through the door this is all
automated through our data warehouse and
then we'll take the patients that are we
would consider high-risk so having a
greater than 10 percent risk of getting
ending up in the ER or getting admitted
that comprises about 38% of patients
that come through the door and then
we'll actually randomized those so there
are a couple of different approaches
that you can have for trying to design a
clinical trial one of them being that
you can use these risk stratification
tools to try to enrich a population for
an event and so it's not for to a
certain extent that sort of a pragmatic
approach of trying to integrate these
models into the clinic and so the
patients that are at high risk will get
randomized to either receiving sort of
standard of care and in this case what I
mean by that if they'll get seen by
their radiation oncologists on the
scheduled basis once a week we see
radiation we see our patients kind of on
an ad hoc basis in addition to the once
a week clinical evaluation but sort of
on a scheduled basis they'll definitely
see their radiation oncologist once a
week and then the other arm is sorted
the UNC study so what we would do is
these patients would also get evaluated
a second time every week in a symptom
management clinic that's staffed by our
nurse practitioner and then the idea is
to try to come
here what the acute event rate is
whether they end up in the hospital or
not in both of these arms there are a
lot of sort of interesting sub questions
- they come up you know how does having
more frequent clinical evaluation impact
patients quality of life while they're
doing their treatment everybody wants to
know the comparison of the physician
versus the computer prediction and then
one question I think that's very
important is what are the reasons for
acute visits because one of the
questions that we still haven't answered
is what kind of admissions or ER visits
are actually preventable and there's
still a lot of controversy about that so
that's I think that's sort of one way
that we can you know try to get these
machine learning tools into a clinical
context absolutely can take advantage of
you know accurate prediction so I'll I
think I'll wrap up on talking a little
bit about sort of the next phases for
improving the accuracy of our model
which is incorporating NLP and so there
have been estimates that 80% the
estimate that I usually hear is that 80%
of the data in the EHR is unstructured
and you know oftentimes they can
complement structured data if you ask
you know if when I go through a patient
chart you know most of the time like the
main thing that I'm reading is like this
clinical narrative that other physicians
are writing about a patient and
sometimes I'll flip through some of the
structured data but that's really like
where most of the attention is spent is
reading clinical notes there are some
encounters they're actually only
captured in clinical notes and so I
mentioned that we see our patients once
every week and most of the data that
comes from when we see them is in the
form of plain text symptoms that we
recognize on a regular basis you know we
often have vitals and weights and things
like that but the clinical data is sort
of where the high yield information is
there and so there's high density
information there and so the idea is try
to combine the unstructured and
structured data together so you know for
example if you have a patient that's
undergoing their treatments we measure
radiation in a unit called gray and so
let's say you have a patient that's
progressing there through their
treatment they're getting more radiation
the structured data gives you some
insights because you know like this
patient is losing weight as they go
through their treatment and then you
also know that they're taking more pain
medications as they're going through
treatment so they might be like headed
on like a bad trajectory as they're
going through now if you complement that
with some of the text data that you can
get out of the clinical notes you know
some we have more information and you
know in theory you can try to take that
information to give you a more accurate
prediction about whether or not
someone's going to end up in the ER or
in the hospital and so you have this
patient that's like essentially eating
only a liquid diet you know that's not
something that's representative
structured data in any form it's only
represented in the unstructured data so
I think that there's a pretty good
familiarity here with ctags which is a
rule-based NLP system basically the gist
is that you can take sit you know
sentences try to tokenize them and turn
them into concepts that are present in
different standardized dictionaries and
so we you see takes version 4.0 and so
you know for example if you have this
clinical note you know this is kind of a
fake note that I wrote for a patient
that would be in our clinic so if
patient comes in you know we're looking
for symptoms like so they're getting the
prostate cancer we talk about hematuria
C takes can actually recognize that
pretty accurately it also does negations
fairly reasonably and and so then you
end up with you know as a structured
form of the unstructured data where you
have a negation for a sno-med term that
represents hematuria and so we've kind
of added on this extra data that tells
us you know this patient is having X Y Z
symptom and then you know that it's
negated and so this is really
preliminary data that we'll be
presenting hopefully updates on at a mia
in the fall but these are sort of the
symptoms that if you look at you know
grossly patients that are going through
radiation treatment whether or not they
had an event or not there are certain
things that are just sort of in general
more associated with with having acute
events that are noted in the chart
there's also a lot of stuff I cleaned
out this table but there's also a lot of
interesting data I think to be gleaned
from whether or not physicians to report
normals because we tend to report
most more frequently when someone's
having a more thorough examination and
so there's some interesting stuff there
but it's always you know so hard to
determine like how how that if like how
that knowledge will influence like how
people will document things in the chart
and so that's the current stage of what
we're adding and I think with that I can
wrap up so just a couple acknowledgments
Jesse as I've mentioned a bunch of times
has been an excellent bioinformatics
mentor this is her and me and my now
nine month old son at a mia this spring
Manisha palta is our primary clinical
mentor she does GI at Duke done it's
wiki's are by a statistician I think
very important to have biases the tissue
statisticians involved especially in the
development of trying to implement tools
in the clinic I should always give props
my brother who works on the categorical
competition with me and then we have
some funding from the Duke endowment and
thanks to dr. Hurst dr. Thomas dr.
Thompson Lin and Lindsay for
coordinating my visits and I will wrap
it up there
Thanks so I think I'll take the liberty
of asking the first question I can think
of a lot I would want to ask you I want
to give others but I was looking at your
clinical trial protocol yeah and
wondering what kind of power it's gonna
take to discern a difference because you
know and this is always a challenge with
informatics tools because they in
essence become the treatment and so you
know have you done a power calculation
will you have enough patient yeah
detected if so we treat we treat 2,000
patients per year which probably could
have figured out from the that one slide
so based on that the the power
calculation ended up being about a
hundred patients in each arm so we would
certainly be able to hit that if you
know we had pretty solid enrollment on
the study it's you know that is grounded
in you know the event rate of the
standard arm with
be about 20% 15 to 20 percent and then
you would expect at least based on the
UNC data about a 30% decrease and so
it's about a hundred I think like 101
patients in each arm so the term
automated what is automated hovering
mean that was in the jail PE article
from the pen group hover automated
hovering I'm not quite sure I don't know
if anyone else knows
I recently heard about a slide scanner
an automated slide scanner that can
automatically segment as you are looking
through in your field of view on a slide
that might be something well could be
related could be like an eye tracking
integration system so it's watching what
you're saying and then trying to trace I
had a different question I'm curious
about one of the secondary analyses up
there yes physician vs. ml projection
yeah
so and and based on your tone of voice I
think I think I think you probably think
the same way I am yes probably is is it
really important which one wins in that
question yeah well I think that's heard
a certain extent right the question is
like if a physician was as accurate in
identifying patients as the computer
then there's no need to go through the
whole process right because the
physician themselves could identify you
know who's at high risk sure I guess but
I mean I it's me the first step before
you even get there right is does the
output of the algorithm help the
physician right yeah which would require
I mean obviously this would be beyond
the scope of the study design that were
required a different clinical trial yes
but to me that would be a more
potentially interesting question than
yeah who wins you know those the was
that this the steam drill versus the
yeah the hammer so that is an excellent
question and a very excellent point so
when I was originally designing the
clinical trial actually related to dr.
Hirsch is comment about powering it was
originally designed as a much more
complex trial as you could imagine
and so the IDE originally wanted to do
have multiple randomization arms we had
physician by themselves positioned with
the aid of the computer and then
computer directed and then within each
of those arms you had the intervention
or not because then you can answer a
whole series of questions
based on that that becomes a hugely
hairy clinical trial to put together and
so for the sake of like trained designed
something pragmatic we ended up
simplifying things to what I thought I
could get done in the department well I
mean that makes perfect sense it's
completely reasonable right so it makes
me wonder maybe maybe it's not important
then for the ml to win but for the
machine learning prediction to show
something new that the physicians may
not catch yeah because that could be
grounds for a future study yeah and I
think that's sort of in some ways I
think related to the like having the
physician be augmented by the output
from them from the algorithm because
then you have to you have two votes
fundamentally right and in some cases
the physicians probably going to be
better and in some cases the computer is
going to be better and they don't
necessarily have to be competing
directly like you're saying it's a great
talk about you know diving into this a
little bit more again you know acute
event yeah how are you defining this
obviously it's right presumably it's
very cancer specific and so that you
mentioned about weight loss and
nutritional status right and someone
who's not been sustaining their vital
signs so then okay they need hydration
oh my god you gotta get the ers right
all right that kind of thing is one path
that someone may take but there's
multiple other paths that someone may
take to get the yarn have a
quote-unquote acute event and presumably
that's related to a lot of other
clinical factors so what is your thought
on the kind of routes to the to the ER
and predicting an event rating or all
events considered equivalent and or is
really the model predicting the same
thing yeah so the model itself as as
it's currently put together basically
predicts it's a binary is this patient
going to end up in the ER or get
hospitalized which you know I think it's
a very it is a way to try to simplify
the problem but there are so many other
questions right like you know if someone
is ending up in the ER very frequently
during their treatment there's still
kind of just as a one even though
they're this you know high sore volume
type person and certainly there are a
lot of different routes and they're also
a lot of causes for admission so you
know we see Tate we see patients like
every you know every week and there
our watch for like up to seven weeks but
a patient might end up in the ER for
something that's not necessarily related
to their cancer and something the
question is will you know how how
important is it for us to be able to
recognize that with the aim of the
machine learning algorithm and I think
that a lot of that depends on what your
objective is because I think if your
objective is to find patients that are
at high risk for ending up with an event
then even though it's unrelated I think
that they're sort of you know still on
our watch and it's important to predict
that but I think that those are all like
the at least of reasons for admission
question is one thing that I think we're
definitely going to tabulate pretty
thoroughly on our trial because I think
it's a question that's come up like a
fair amount as we've discussed the
project and then you know I think that
we've thought about like other endpoints
as well that sort of our different
points on like the road to the to the ER
and I think those are all sort of fair
game for things that you know maybe you
can be more systematic in trying to make
like a prediction for those things but
you know with the all with all cause
like ER or hospital visit is sort of the
most analogous think that compares with
the endpoint that was used in the UNC
data and so because we kind of have data
on like what that intervention can do
with that endpoint that's kind of how we
designed the algorithm hi great talk
thank you um so I I'm sure you're
probably aware of the study but there
was even Bausch out of Mount Sinai did a
really nice study that's very similar
set up to this where he used patient
reported outcomes and I'm curious to
know whether you've thought of because
one of the arguments or like suggestions
you said was you know it's very it's
very resource intensive to have the
symptom management clinics implemented
yeah and you know his his argument after
like running the study was bit like you
know actually it you know you can reduce
the amount of soot events and his
definition of that I think was like ER
visit yeah and so I'm curious to know
whether you could use some of these like
use the machine learning predictions to
essentially be like okay well can we
can we get to the same point as what you
would if you actually had patients like
reporting this in it like an automated
system yeah so the East the Ethan Bausch
data is actually pretty interesting for
just to kind of describe that so
basically what they did was I think they
incorporated a PR a patient reported
outcome system online where patients
could report sort of what their symptoms
were online and they actually found that
patients had a much lower rate of ending
up in the ER and they actually their
clinical outcomes were actually better
in the in the patient reported outcome
group and they you know randomized
patients to either approach which I
think it's pretty profound and speaks
the power of like having these like
commute systems that allow for direct
communication between a physician and a
patient and so I think I mean I thought
that was study was like a great study to
the first answer I'll give is kind of
not really it's answering the question
that wasn't asked but I think patient
reported outcomes are a really important
I think that a you know improved
collection of patient reported outcomes
is in particular like an important goal
in oncology and particularly I think in
radiation because we see patients so
often they can be giving us a lot of
information there's a we've kind of
talked about some collaborations with
folks that have had that have
high-quality patient reported outcomes
as far as their toxicity during
treatments but it's mostly been along
the lines of discussing how we can use
NLP systems in relation to that because
they have high quality data and we can
we can both think about you know how
well NLP works because there a lot of
limitations to NLP and its current state
and also the comparison you know we
always thought I think we talk often
about the comparison between physician
reported outcomes and patient reported
outcomes and their discrepancies there
and so I think that's a really
interesting source of data as far as
building prediction models for those
outcomes I think it depends on the
specific outcome because I think that if
it kind of comes back down to like sort
of what what is the question that you're
asking and what is the data that you
have and how well can that data
approximate what your outcome is but you
know
you I think that we're often surprised
about things that can give us predictive
information even it's not causal Jesse's
favorite example is that I think Nigam
Shah did a study looking at mortality
and one of the things that they liked
found which in retrospect is
unsurprising was it had to do with you
know whether or not they called in like
religious services like you know at a
certain time because you know those
increased mortality is shortly following
like thereafter and so you know there's
always I think these techniques it's
always that balance of like going in
with with or without a hypothesis and
sometimes you're surprised and if it
makes sense like like in that example
you know it's useful information it's a
you know so thank you
hopefully I answered enough of the
question that was asked okay well before
we finish I want to present this this is
XE and in fact I should acknowledge my
fellow department chair dr. Charles
Thomas is the chair of radiation
oncology and for those of you who have
noted when Charles comes here he and I
were high school classmates so there's
we're the only high school for which
there are two school of medicine
departments years we always point that
out in public
anyways um he brought this as a token of
appreciation for dr. Hong coming to
visit us and we'll hope he'll be here in
the future so thank you all for coming
today
thanks for listening
[Applause]